the first day of university i went and
bought like uh a crate of pot noodles
ripped off them that was beautiful you
can't go wrong with port noodles though
we probably get back onto japanese food
well going back to well going back to
jail
like i recently funnily enough i just
went to the cup ramen museum in yokohama
oh yeah yeah yeah which the only reason
we went to the cabral museum was just
because it was there it was just there
it was like
whatever it's something to do but it was
actually like really interesting and
really fun it was
not some it was not some place i thought
to go that would be like a fun exciting
place to go but
it was fun to learn about cup ramen like
i did i had no idea that basically cup
ramen
like exists because of americans because
like
instant noodle was instant noodle was
like invented right
in like the usual packeted packeted way
and then they tried to sell it to
america
and americans were just like how do we
eat this well you have to use a [ __ ]
chopstick with bowls
like this that's too inefficient so they
just start putting it in like their soda
cans
or the no not the soda cans the soda
soda cups
just like poured like put put the ramen
in and just and just uh put water hot
water in yeah and that's how cup ramen
was invented
oh wow yeah it was i think an american
invention yeah well it's it's
it was invented in japan the method of
doing the with the noodles yeah but it
was when they tried to sell it to
americans
he saw americans doing that and he was
like let's just put it in the [ __ ]
cup so
thank you america for for cup ramen and
uh yeah if you're in prison uh it's your
currency
is your i mean that one vox video it's
actually currency
that's so funny but yeah in terms of
like japanese food
what's is like what are some japanese
food you you want more people to know
about or that you have discovered
since moving to japan that maybe not
many people like know about well you
know my answer
yeah i i mean i already know you are so
we've talked about this before go on go
on joey
sim for your sim for your dish go on yes
i'm sipping for a little dish called
skimming it's not ramen it's skim man so
basically
skim in to oversimplify think of ramen
but separate the noodles from the broth
and make that broth
thick as a [ __ ] i i will say
[Music]
when i was first like i saw it on the
menu i was like why the [ __ ] would i
want my noodles separated from the boat
yeah
that sounds like it's like de-marinating
yeah yeah an extra step right yeah it
sounded like it was just making the
noodles
less flavorful but it just didn't make
any logical sense but somehow
it makes the noodles even more flavorful
when you dip them into this and you
basically have the broth on the noodles
right
because because the thing with ramen
broth is that it's very liquidy because
the noodle
is going to be sitting in this broth for
a long long time
maybe you can drink it and you can drink
it right but skim and broths
they have to make it thick because when
you put the noodles in and then you take
it out again
as you said the broth has to stick to
the noodles yeah and that [ __ ] is
the flavor of that is so [ __ ]
powerful and then
yeah and then when you're done eating
the noodles you can pour like a soup
into the broth to like dilute it to make
it it's it's basically like concentrated
ramen
yeah basically the first time but like
i don't know because i feel like no
matter what we say or how much we try to
sell it
you can't sell it in words right now
because it just it doesn't look as
pretty as ramen ramen is so pretty and
like you explain it logically and you're
just like
that just sounds like robin with extra
steps yeah what makes that sound exactly
what you guys said when i tried to sell
it to you guys and i was like trust me
let's go to my favor one of my favorite
skimming places in ikebukuro
and you can just eat it and tell me yeah
and i took them and i remember we were
like chatting the biggest
the madder [ __ ] be like yeah sure joey
sure whatever and then
we got the dish and we just sat there in
like silence for a good like 10 minutes
i was as we were just eating this and i
remember like i was
like i remember the second place you
took me to i swear it took me had like i
had like an existential crisis eating
this
man i remember you before eating you you
were just staring at me and i was just
like looking at this bowl of
i was just eating this ball of cigarette
being just like it's perfect it's it's
perfect i'll tell you what it felt like
it felt like that meme in like
ratatouille where you know
where you had i had like one bite and he
just like took me back to my childhood
or something like that like
i was having like a flashback to like
this dish like grandma made me like my
grandma's never made me
took him in but it like gave me that
same homely feeling
that that i had when like eating like a
home-cooked meal like back as a kid
and i was like what is happening right
i've never seen anyone have a food wars
moment in real life
that was legitimately the closest i've
ever seen dude i was this close to like
[ __ ] crying
i remember i i stopped to like because
he was sitting opposite me and i was
eating and i looked over and you were
kind of just
like silently staring at it and i
remember i said to you i'm like
are your eyes watering are you like
really about to cry
no that that that is uh that definitely
did meanwhile i was just there in my
mind like [ __ ] tyler1 like yeah
i'm just [ __ ] eating it like and then
i remember the next day
we were you know talking about you know
whatever the [ __ ] we were talking about
and god
just texted like fully serious being
like i had a dream about that
i actually had a dream about that ski
man because it's not [ __ ] good
as well because they like have the the
meat and all the veg in the broth
when you bite into like the veg or the
meat they have absorbed this intense
broth and it just bursts
and it's so [ __ ] and the meat is so
soft and just so
tender so tender like honestly like i'm
not gonna say that the ramen in japan
is bad or anything like there's some
[ __ ] fantastic ramen out there but i
just feel that
skimming is such an underdog because
people just as you say
people just think that it's just an
inferior ram yeah i mean that's what i
thought and i didn't even know about
succumbing until i moved here and you
told me about
it and i feel like people only come here
and they only know ramen
when i came here i only knew ramen as
well i totally don't blame people who
are like oh yeah i just want to eat
sushi and i just want to eat ramen
but it just frustrates me when there's
literally you go to a ramen shop and
they usually have skim in on the menu as
well
yeah and yet they just completely ignore
that and just go for like the basic
[ __ ] ramen
yeah and i feel like you know you you do
get a better ramen experience here than
you do
like anywhere else in the world yeah it
just frustrates me when people are like
i'm gonna go to ichiran ramen and it's
like you can have a nichiren in america
dude why would you fly all the way to
japan to have something you can have in
america
like i do not understand why you know
people come to japan
and they try like what what's the coco
what's the curry place
is it coco curry that's like like
international one yeah
yeah yeah i don't know why they come
here and just try the coco curry right
in defense of both those chains i'll
i'll be devil's advocate
i went to ichiran ramen like maybe a
month ago i thought it was pretty
[ __ ] good
i thought it was like it's not bad yep
okay it's
just mid okay it is
if you don't live here right and you
don't want to [ __ ] around with going
down these alleyways looking on google
maps right trying to find [ __ ] i can
understand where you're like i want a
good ramen
that delivers and i and i don't have to
talk 21 they have an english menu i get
that because sometimes these ramen
places
bro no pictures only kanji you gotta you
gotta give your ticket to the guy
you gotta hope that he calls you out and
you know that it's you right yeah that's
a little you know
you know you gotta figure out if he's
asking you guys if you want extra badge
or whatever
because you hand it to him and he'll be
like you know he'll ask what size and
you'll be like
what or like do you want rice rice they
have some
yeah sometimes and because the word for
rice and meal is the same gohan go home
and
one time they asked me gohan i just
completely forgot that it was rice and
i'm like yeah i want a meal i just gave
you my ticket
you dumb [ __ ] take my ticket yeah i know
that's goku's son
yeah so i mean i get it where it's you
on ramen okay it was a little expensive
though i'll give you that yeah
the the noodles were thin though it was
good i you know i want to start a series
where i go around reviewing ramen change
yeah but that's the problem i have with
ichiran right is that it is the thin
noodles and like i don't have a problem
with the thin noodles but
i like my noodles like i like my women
right like i like them thick
i was like wondering what you were going
to do joey's like the inappropriate
uncle that has to mention
like something sexual every time it's
the only way people relate to me
but yeah like that's what that's what i
love about skimming though is that like
those noodles are so [ __ ] thick
so there's so there's like it's okay but
it's i remember the first place you took
me to it was like
trying to go to an weekly buffet with
like this this one little noodle dish
because it was so
thick yeah yeah i remember i saw you
guys finishing it and i wasn't even like
halfway through i'm like
it was like doing the big bang burger
challenge in like persona 5. you know
what i mean
that's that was kind of what i felt like
i i got what the
determination point no i didn't i didn't
i need to i need to like upgrade more
points man
okay in japan there's like what three
main types of noodles right
there's the the soba noodles the udon
and the ramen rice yes
which okay and the difference between
these are the the soba ones are
typically like healthy quite thin
is buckwheat buckwheat it's quite
healthy for you yeah it's definitely the
healthiest
yes is ramen the least healthy for you
ramen
i mean i don't know there's a lot of
calories in right yeah ramen i'd say
it's probably
probably the most healthy and there's
udon so rama's kinda like in the middle
so sober's really thin it tastes healthy
so
make up that what you want and then uh
udon is the real [ __ ] thick boy and
like
why why why why does sober taste healthy
i don't understand
because it is healthy i know it is but
i'm just like what what is the big
difference between
sober and ramen i'm trying to like put
it into words now i'm just like i think
maybe it's because a lot of sober dishes
aren't
sitting in this very like so it doesn't
hit back bro
yeah sober just goes down yeah ramen
ramen fights you as it's going next time
bro it's like it's a challenge you gotta
like you gotta beat that [ __ ] in your
stomach
also i've noticed ram is sober with
attitude yeah
that's so bad i think because ramen is
so
heavily in calories even the shitty cup
ramens taste [ __ ] good here but yeah
if you go and get like the supermarket
sober that [ __ ] tastes awful yeah yeah
it does taste really bad you need to go
to a good sober place yes
sober restaurants are amazing so yeah in
sober restaurants they give you the
choice of cold sober
and hot sober and as someone who's grown
up with like noodles my entire life
i've grown up with the idea that you
have to have noodles as like a hot dish
yeah because i don't know i don't know
like is it weird for you guys
especially you connor like the the idea
of eating a cold main
dish if there's options i'm always gonna
go hot like yeah i was i went out the
other day and it was like it must have
no this is like two weeks ago i went to
a place
like the ac wasn't working it was like
35 degrees feels like 40. i was like
yeah
the the person asked me do you want hot
or cold i was like
yeah no one else in this restaurant
absolutely
no one else in this restaurant had hot i
could easily see that because you know
it comes in a bowl when it's hot and
when you get the cold it's on like this
little like bamboo thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah and dude i was sweating my ass
off in this restaurant but i still i was
like i'm glad i got home because
i remember yeah i i remember when i
first moved here i was like hot sober
hot sauce
and then i tried cold once and i'm like
oh this is
really refreshing this tastes like it
tastes so totally different
but it still gives me like a good
feeling no i've had it cold it's not bad
i just i
to me cold thing like cold noodles don't
feel like a meal
it feels like a leftover
hot noodles feel like a meal i mean i i
kind of get weird
but it's also very funky it feels like
you found it in your fridge right and
you're like ah
okay all right let's eat it right like
you know is the logic that like you
can't be bothered
to be fair like with when you order cold
or uh a hot
uh soba as well so when you get hot
sober you just get the noodles and the
broth that it comes in
yeah but i always feel jealous of the
cold people who get this the little the
dipping sauce yeah yeah
so with the cold sober you have like
like a little
tiny little spot as a sauce it's like a
shoyu base
i thought so like a soy and it's really
good yeah it's not a broth it's just
like a sauce
and then you dip it in you take you take
out the soba you just dip it in
like whip some wasabi in it and then you
just yeah cold sober is the skimming of
hot soup
oh my god oh my god and further
and then there's the final noodle which
is my least favorite i don't i do not
like you
i really like it dude it genuinely feels
like you're in a tentacle hentai every
time you do that
because you gotta you gotta dude you can
have like two in your mouth and you're
like
trying to force that [ __ ] down yeah it's
awful you can't it's
so heavy it's like swallowing a brick
bro no it's not that bad it is no it
feels like
the vanilla of like the noodle world
where it just
it it hit the same every time what can i
say man and also
because ramen is is somewhat thin right
yeah it can
the the sauce that it takes on to the
ratio of noodle that i'm eating is
perfect
udon it's like this thick in my mind
right that's how thick it feels right
right
this it's like a it's like a coating
okay
but here's the question though do you
guys like mochi yeah like
i like mochi and i'm not talking about
like [ __ ] mochi ice cream [ __ ]
like i'm talking about no no no no
yeah yeah okay because it's like i i
feel a lot of people who don't like
udon are the same people who don't like
mochi for the exact reason right because
when you eat like a block of mochi
that's like eating a brick and it's not
like get that [ __ ] down it's udon is
just like the noodle equivalent yeah but
like
that that i like that because it's kind
of like a sweet you know a lot of times
i like mochi sweets you know because
oh so you've never had savory much
either i've had savory emoji okay how i
probably wouldn't
like yeah it was very like like [ __ ]
like a brick
but i mean i was prepared for it to be a
brick
you know because it's still dessert
right yeah like so i mean i was
different but
like when we went to that sober place a
while ago i know udon place sorry
it was like we had this broth and the
udon just didn't stick any of the broth
to it and i'm like what's the [ __ ]
point
well because it's supposed to be a light
taste it's supposed to be like a really
thin flavorful like umami taste
it
do you think do you think udon is the
worst of the three uh
i don't know like i i i feel like i like
sober and udon equally
but ramen is deaf ramen or rolled
skimming is definitely above those two
but i i like udon like i i don't
i'm not gonna like opt for udon every
single time but yeah
if i went to an udon place i'm not gonna
[ __ ] come see if i if i had the
choice i would like
never go to the udon place i'd like i
would always be more in the mood for
sober or ramen right like there would
never be a point where
udon's where i go to where there's like
no other places around right like
i guess i'll settle for udon yeah there
are just some winter days where i'm like
man i could really go for like a hot
udon yeah i really just want like bricks
in my stomach dude i just
want warm bricks in my stomach with the
sauce not sticking to it
but then you drink the soup afterwards
yeah but sometimes it's too rich then
you know what i mean like come on no no
no no broths are never rich
it's a thick noodle with a light broth
like
i i like my ramen and skimming that have
like a really thick flavor right yeah
it just completely sticks to you no
matter what but some days i'm just like
i don't i don't want to feel like i'm
getting all this like sticky flavor on
me like sometimes i just want to get
something down that'll warm me up
and it's nice and light and will fill me
up but won't make me feel like [ __ ] yeah
yeah
because sometimes when you have as much
as as much as i loved skimming some
like it's like five guys right it's like
yeah man this flavor is so powerful
it sticks to me the entire time but then
the moment it starts to settle in your
stomach you just like
kill me five guys is that thing where
you just like i'm out for the count for
the rest
yeah don't talk to me don't expect me to
do anything like that i never thought
food could knock you out
i have five guys